hello there it's update time a new
fortnight season is with us with new
stories new map changes and new tiny
details about the future i'm adamaru sit
your butt down for five minutes and
let's break down all the map changes in
season four paradise oh and of course
kodamaru pretty please
[Music]
so it happened the reality tree has been
pruned the once thriving tree of life is
now a husk and its biome is wilting away
don't you think that tree is totally
done yet though as the butterflies still
circle it and most of the reality tree
locations from last season are still
intact the tree has now thrown out more
new saplings around the island and
something strange happens if you get too
close you'll find a glow around your
screen something is going to happen in
these locations it is revealed the
chrome is here because of the bloom
watcher or should i say the herald who
is making everything monosyllabic our
new enemy is changing the battlefield
how can the loopers fight such a thing
any contact with that substance and will
end up like three of the seven well the
counter is super simple get everything
off the ground if the goop can't touch
us we are safe right starting here on
spawn island the verticality is clear
many pois are now growing upwards with
balloons and jet powered foundations
supporting the change to avoid that
chrome the battle bus now has its own
budget heli carrier complete with ramp
to get airborne quickly it's not as good
as the one back in season 4 of chapter 2
but it's a good budget effort all the
same on the br island the former daily
bugle which became a pirate's cove has
seen the ship raise into the air as the
entire poi below is covered by that
chrome stuff the theory is proven the
ship is still fine in the air whereas
everything else below it seems to be
lost on the plus side down here as
everything is covered in chrome we can
phase through those walls instantly such
a great mechanic which means a hidden
pirate treasure map can be found sealed
inside four walls
over to tilted towers the crew at no
sweat insurance are taking no chances
their legendary building is already
above ground hoisted by a huge balloon
and a jack underneath they must have
been taking inspiration from apex
legends again air balloons to redeploy
good idea no sweat may be all about
profit but we gotta hand it to them they
take their job seriously those balloons
are scattered all over the place and
when visiting them you can see there is
more to come they are building something
wood is being stacked and cut ready to
build more i'm thinking maybe we'll be
getting a sky city an unexpected change
was the return of the io blimp at the
rave cave i was perplexed by this but
likely it was recommissioned by the
seven to once again get as many people
off the ground as possible over at the
zero point things seem calm well at
least this week the tethers are still in
place connecting it to the reality tree
and things continue as normal the big
change seems to be forcing loopers back
to work all the casino and pool tables
and fun things they were doing last
season including batman's favorite
inflatable unicorn have been stacked up
ready to be thrown away there is no more
time for vibing close by we have a
potential huge change to look at look at
what we have here it's the house which
once sat on loot lake from all the way
back in chapter one you remember it
right somehow it's rocked up here after
all this time it got here through a
crack above it you know it might be just
be me but i'm thinking is this here for
the spooky season because last time it
was here it went around the island on
the back of a cube get your guesses in
early why is this place returning it has
to be for halloween and also we should
probably keep an eye on that crack in
the sky one crack started this entire
story off
remember the yellow house that was
destroyed during the battle for tilted
towers during the resistance season well
last season work began on restoration
and for 15 weeks it sat there the same
luckily right now it's back it's not
that fantastic yellow anymore it's this
ming and green color but hey there's a
secret here smash the bookcase and
you'll discover the basement is actually
a seven covert location complete with an
io hollow table transformed into the
seventh branding a super secret base in
a super secret house in the middle of
the map down here is an immovable sealed
door with a plinth inside this must be
our mission location for the season and
in there could be where we put samples
safely so it doesn't touch us or it
could be a prison cell if you get four
keys please try this i want to know what
it does speaking of locks a new mechanic
this season are vaults and keys instead
of key cards absolutely everywhere they
can be found and each vault is themed to
the area for example the no sweat bunker
is yellow and has its side inside the
one in the south west of the island has
mushrooms on show for all you fun guys
and there are even hidden ones to find
too just south of tilted towers on the
hill you'll see a big pile of timber
ready to be sawn take the time to smash
those and you'll find a secret bunker
underneath this one has a stag's head on
the wall do me a favor and let me know
if you spot any of these with easter
eggs inside i'm hoping to find midas's
golden chair somewhere soon
over to the herald a vortex of chrome
sits in the shape of a tornado spreading
that metallic substance everywhere but
there's a bad thing here remember the
seven rock statues they once were here
now they are not anymore they taught us
the lore about the seven and now they're
gone maybe like the seven also gone is
the main spot of sanctuary replaced with
a chrome castle built from towers of
hexagons solid and unwavering the
herald's throne is pretty intimidating
too and at some point you'll fight her
good luck with that if you choose not to
fight you'll witness her watching
something what is she doing here if you
have a theory please share it
[Music]
okay let's get into the stuff that
really matters the bromance since they
reappeared on our island and made a new
friend we followed all their shenanigans
i honestly thought after they picked up
their fourth member and i watched them
right into the sunset their story was
over but oh no it continues if you're
lucky enough to spot the bros either as
a foursome or in duos take a look around
peering from afar is fenja the sevens
guard who patrolled around sanctuary she
can be spotted creeping up and spying on
them without being noticed there's two
ways we can see this is she keeping tabs
on the lads or the option i prefer she
wants to join them this duo which became
a trio which became a foursome may have
a fifth member soon which means it's big
enough for a faction i reckon it's time
to upgrade this from a bromance into an
official new faction name i challenge
you to come up with a name we can call
this group of people all these misfits
hang on why don't we just call them
misfits anyway if you've got if you've
got a suggestion throw it in the
comments below and starting next update
i will start to use that instead of
bromance i kind of like misfits though
we've come a long way since that dance
off at a roadside cafe the other story i
wanted to talk to you all about were the
rock family and truckasaurus but i'm
gutted to report both are missing all
those weeks of progress gone completely
vanished could they have been taken by
the chrome or has epic just forgotten
all about them
was anyone else looking forward to
seeing a chrome rock family and a chrome
truck asaurus okay just me so that's the
update how did i do did you spot
something i didn't please let me know in
the comments below and i'll add it next
update i'm adam you're awesome here's
some legends to use my code have a great
season i'll see you next time
[Music]
you